prep football is the biggest and most
popular high school sport but it has
taken major hits during the covet
pandemic with games or even entire
seasons getting sacked across the
country there is a shortage of football
officials chris matthews here live in
studio to tell us how in southern nevada
they've actually managed just fine yeah
they'll have brian which is kind of
surprising certainly not ideal and the
members of the southern nevada officials
association have had to scramble adjust
and really use their best managing
skills to make it work
on any given sunday there are about 20
prep games in southern nevada using five
officials for varsity games other states
use four and only one since the start of
the season has there been an officiating
shortage at the varsity level at all
levels one eight two eight three eight
four
a all games have been covered fully
except for one game
had four officials instead of five but
it did not have any effect or outcome of
the game normally there would be a pool
of 270 officials here in southern nevada
they're down about 120 but with
cancellations or games being postponed
it's freed up officials to work other
games so that no game is left without a
five-man crew and there's one more
reason the school district scheduling
some of those games on saturday which
freed up officials to work those games
the commissioner of officials mark
ratner telling us tonight that the
shortage is real there is a concern
moving forward but until the pandemic is
over the guys and stripes who get paid
58 dollars a game will continue to make
it work for most of us it was a good
year and a half between the
opportunities to get on the field
and the common conversation was kids
were happy to be out there coaches were
happy to be out there and we were happy
to be out there
all right so lots of games on a friday
night here in las vegas southern nevada
always full of friday night football
might point out also that because of the
pandemic lots of training has been done
on zoom calls and not in person on the
field so that has been a challenge as
well denise